the bad guys is really cool
it's crime time baby it's slightly
dangerous it's witty and it's quick a
little crazy crazy you finally speaking
my language chico
we're the villains of every story the
animals we are scared of
they're the best at being bad they're
the best criminals so long suckers
if you want to stay out of jail you need
to go good it's definitely a struggle
for them it's a cat stuck in a tree
i want you to
smack it in it stab it saute it sing to
it save it i want you to set and that's
so obvious i want you to save it oh
right
the cast is phenomenal insane everybody
really brings in their personality to
the characters and really shapes them
it's a real stretch cranky inflated
sense of self
yeah i had to really uh work on that at
home this is going to taste extra sweet
nope
sucka does it i'll teach you to share
totally worth it
the action and the drama you're going to
laugh out loud
i'm having a baby
there's a lot of heartfelt stuff going
on too
you think you see an animation you think
you haven't
[Music]
what happened did we blow up
is this heaven
[Music]